hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the sims 4 we are
leaving the applier family no we're not
leaving the applier family we're leaving
that we're going back to the applier
family and we're gonna see how
everyone's doing so let's play the game
with me and wait and Bob and see what
kind of trouble that we can get into I
can't hear myself properly this
microphone isn't working in the last
episode we built all of our characters
to the exact specifications that they
are in real life because we're all
robots apparently and now we got a
little house that everyone's gonna know
and love and enjoy
so I guess somebody be playing Wade
which I haven't played sims 4 in a long
time I actually did it just for funsies
a while ago but oh there they go okay
finally okay yeah you go off and you do
your thing guys oh what a wonderful
happy family that we are here together
watch TV oh man
things are things are destiny to be
exactly as I do
okay yeah I guess Wade's done then
alright wait wait no that's Oh talk to
self from being insane are you insulting
the TV unpleasant conversation
bob is bored I know that Bob would be
bored this is horrifying we're never
gonna get along at least I'm happy or I
think I'm happy I kind of have a
permanent smile on my face
I mean besides all the permanence Foose
hi Bob
hi Wade that's good it seems like the
normal conversations with you guys
actually stop thinking about me then
don't do that rayful I think this is
working out perfectly because already
everyone doesn't like Wade oh I'm so not
sorry I almost don't want to tell them
to actually do anything because it's
kind of hilarious I love a certain level
of autonomy in the world but I don't
want to just be a silent observer
in case anyone was wondering this is
actually what happens in our lives
Wow okay bye wait me and Bob were
talking about how stupid weight is and
what the hell he's doing don't think
about the fire we had a problem with
fire in the last episode geez not the
last episode but you know what I mean
hug someone wait just wants to hug
someone okay again
wait why apparently being insane means
that weight has some absolutely no shame
okay so we gotta do something with our
lives because otherwise we're not gonna
be able to ever do anything at all so
Bob needs to be the responsible one of
the bunch and actually go find a job go
Bob go I'm sorry that your life has to
be so boring and you have to be the
adult but me and Wade we can't handle
being responsible human so okay select a
career for Bob detective doctor or
scientist ooh I think Bob could be a
scientist Bob could be a really cool
scientist that might mean that we get
some Oh didn't we try to be a scientist
before and then we tried to launch a
rocket and that didn't work out so well
I don't know
flew for warm bath I don't know what
that means
okay also wait you're gonna try to find
a job too because I think it'll be
hilarious if we try to actually do
something with your life all right
for some reason Wade's gonna be an
astronaut now I don't have much hope for
this but hey good for him he's gonna try
real hard but you try already boom and
then me too I'm gonna do something
because I find a job I guess we should
all find a good near good ear
microbots oh okay I guess I could be a
detective
it's kind of part of the new ones I
guess for a doctor I always wanted to be
a doctor or a detective now I'm a doctor
at least hopefully we're trying to get
along now maybe we won't but you know
wait we are friends and friends do hang
out and get along all the time Bob you
don't need to be so sad about everything
that we talked about how didn't even
know what we are to each other I think
we're just a whole lot of nothing really
have nothing else to do besides talk to
each other oh god wait why you're
soiling your hotdog suit okay all right
then I mean we're really trying but I
think it's just gonna turn out that
we're gonna be enemies later and now I'm
a god dammit I mean everyone had the
common courtesy to God's Wade's stop
being crazy we just stop wait wait wait
because way needs to be stopped for
whatever the hell he's doing right now
all right I'm gonna provoke him we have
such a dysfunctional relationship over
there weirdest game I've ever played
throw drink afraid uh-huh she needs IVA
thing okay I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
I can take out all my aggression on Wade
right here and now fight me bro we both
see what you can do with your stick arms
and your big butt and your chicken logs
and all many feet I got big feet and big
biceps
now I'm going to apologize because I'm
dazed then completely odd no no no Daisy
all right apologize from doable hey stop
being so confrontational and apologize
but Gordon a forgiveness thank you back
on your knees to the all-powerful wave
or fight more never mind
I guess that's not happening hi Bob
sorry to intrude on everything that
you're doing imply mother is a llama I
mean she is but come on Oh what's Bob
doing
Bob's having a brain wave something over
there be friendly outside of our gothic
doors if while Bob's doing whatever the
hell Bob's doing I have no idea
true there we go now friends I wish I
could actually take naps
I cannot nap for the life of me my other
roommates say that I should nap hi Bob
again with the naked bath I mean I put
that stilt bath in there but I didn't
think that anyone would actually believe
that is stealth bad it's not hi Bob
looks good Bob how you doing Bob you
look so sad oh it's the first day your
hearty just sick of her [ __ ]
oh poor Bob man I think they up the
insanity little thin Sims for because
weight is way more insane people is a
blessed one okay we need to find common
ground we got to find a a group activity
to do this so that we can all not
destroy each other's brains oh yeah
that's right we tried to build a
spaceship I guess we could try to build
a spaceship again but I don't hope it'd
work out too well it didn't go too well
last time Hey persistent gets the early
Lama something I don't know something
Sims related okay we bought a spaceship
now everybody go out and get
get working on it I think cuz we did
this last time and it's gonna be really
difficult go go buddies go go go go
okay he acquired the rocket science
skill well I think Bob was gonna be a
sign sir something tells me you
shouldn't hit a rocket with a hammer
because of all the rocket fuel and
explosive stuff like that you know it
might not be good for it oh well I'll
just be naked in here taking a bath you
guys have fun I'm watching the ballerina
do things well I guess that's it for me
then you guys work late into the night
don't worry about me I'll be fine oh I
guess I'm up now never mind
and taking another bath I really did not
mean for that to be the TV bathtub
I meant that it for the to be the TV
toilet but whatever okay back in bed I
guess just got up for a late night bath
whoo I'm feeling I'm feeling well I
don't know why I'm flirty over a meal
but hello hi how's it go wait wait I'm
feeling flirty wait flirty introduction
come back here I'm doing a thing I'll be
there in just a second don't you worry
about me I'm on the why did you change
clothes but hey I'm not complaining just
give me a second
buff man coming through this going much
better than last time
I don't smell bad at all don't mind the
explosions behind me it's just the
initial parts of our love goodbye other
person thank you for standing in my way
I'll be with you in just a second okay
go away forever out of my life Alice
Spencer Kim's oh whoa hey wait wait come
back here hey come back here hey how
about a flirty introduction for you too
don't be so sad about Barbie you want a
flirty introduction to old man well yeah
all right okay I'm flirting with okay
bye well I mean
you didn't okay good thing I'm being for
me to show off I'm the one that's gonna
be showing off here hello wait no no no
no no wait no no no I was gonna do
push-ups
you ruined my chances let me share my
brilliant ideas with you
that's a nice moustache I'm glad all the
ladies left and it's just you and me man
Wow I'll give you all my life to be
do I like Alice or Zoey I don't know I
don't like weight obviously man how how
much did I ruin our relationship in just
a tiny amount of time I guess is the
effective weight that's on people it's
not my fault obviously it's just weighed
well I guess that's the end of a good
first day so I will do better next time
they're gonna keep working until they're
exhausted and blowing themselves up over
and over again because they're tired
accomplished more in the next episode so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know if you're enjoying the
series down in the comments below thank
you again and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye I feel like
this would lead to a lot more problems
than just was seen on the surface so do
you have December 2nd
really now I look like an [ __ ]